-How is your --
is your dog, Petunia,
enjoying the quality time
she's getting with you?
-I think she is.
She's snoring.
I don't know if this audio
can pick it up.
She's laying on a little towel
She's enjoying it.
I think it took her a couple -
It took her more than a week
to realize what was happening,
which is that
we weren't going anywhere.
We've taken her out
on the street a couple times
safely, with a mask on.
Totally kidding.
-Right.
-Her face is flat.
It would suffocate her.
-[ Laughs ]
-And she just looks around
like, empty streets, like...
Like, no one anywhere.
And it's really weird to a dog
-Yeah. Our dog is --
-Her whole life,
she's at leg level.
And now there's none.
-Yeah.
There's no legs
to mark exactly how tall she is.
-There's no legs.
She doesn't know -- yeah.
She can't tell a quarter
from the Statue of Liberty
She's got no --
[ Both laugh ]
--Without legs.
-You went back.
You hosted "SNL"
for a third time.
-Yeah, and then the world ended.
-Yeah, and the world ended
And in February, right?
February.
-It was leap year, Saturday,
February 29th.
-And you -- you had to cance
a stand-up show in Canada?
-Yeah. I --
Yeah, but I'm --
I'm gonna get there real soon.
-So, Toronto, yes?
-Toronto, Canada.
-Yeah.
-Supposed to perform
in the fall.
Had an emergency.
Truly had an emergency,
couldn't perform.
By the way, no one cares.
They're still mad at me
for canceling the first time
I can tell them my legs
were chopped off,
and they'd be like,
"Well, you should've let
ticket owners know."
Then weather-related
cancellation.
Then I rescheduled
for February 28th.
And I say, "There's no way
this is gonna be cancelled."
Then I cancelled it
for "Saturday Night Live."
Now it's going to be rescheduled
for the fourth time real soon.
-You had Lorne
write a letter for you.
-Yes, Lorne is the --
I think he has
a dukedom in Canada.
-Yeah.
-Or a fiefdom or something
So he's a Knight of the Orde
of Canada.
And he'd tell you that,
and so --
-Wait. He wears --
He's got the little button
-They have a little button
yeah.
-A lapel pin.
I should make clear, it's not,
I don't think, a button.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not a -- No.
It doesn't have a pin
on the back, and it says,
"I'm in Canada."
It's small,
understated lapel pin.
Looks very nice.
So he wrote a letter
to his own people
to ask for their forgiveness
for me missing the date.
-Yeah.
-And it was very nice.
And I am really excited
to see the people of Toronto
And I do --
This isn't like a life bit
where I keep can canceling
the show for fun.
I'm not a sociopath
in that way.
I recognize
how that would be funny.
But I am not
currently doing that.
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, all the good people
of Canada and every great nation
has a chance to hear you
and Nick Kroll.
And we'll be right back to tal
to talk about the
"Oh, Hello: the P'dcast"
right after this.
-Thank you.